GORDON RAMSAY: I've
still got lots to learn,
so I'm off to try a
traditional Christmas
dish that I hear tastes
much better than it smells.
Now, trust me, I want to
get the best of Christopher,
and I'm up here to meet two guys
who make this amazing delicacy
that can only be found here.
[music playing]
First of all, I'm
excited to see and taste
this incredible delicacy
that is rockfish.
Rakfisk.
[inaudible]
MAGNUS: Rakfisk.
- Fisk.
Rakfisk.
Rockfish, no.
OK.
(VOICEOVER) After what
seems like hours are saying
the same thing back and forth,
[inaudible] and his nephew
Magnus show me how they make
the crown jewel of their family
business-- fermented fish.
What a smell.
Very strong.
Is that normal, that strong?
MAGNUS: Yeah.
Trout, and what
is that one there?
This is Arctic char.
GORDON RAMSAY: Arctic char.
And how long do you cure it for?
It's in for three months.
GORDON RAMSAY: Bloody hell.
So you pack it with
salt. And then--
Sugar as well.
GORDON RAMSAY: Sugar.
So it cures it.
Yeah, exactly.
And how old is this method?
Dates back to the Viking age.
Now it's more popular than ever.
Shall we?
MAGNUS: First, you put salt
in the belly, like this.
And you just put
them in the bucket.
And then it's
heads, tails, heads,
tails all the way through.
Opposite.
And you build.
MAGNUS: Exactly.
GORDON RAMSAY: (VOICEOVER)
Sounds pretty straightforward--
or so I thought.
But the rakfisk master
is not impressed.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Too much?
MAN: Too much.
Too much.
Less.
Less salt. How's
that one, uncle?
MAN: Ah, good.
Good?
Thank god for that.
I've never seen this
method before like this.
It's only here in the
[inaudible] and [inaudible]..
GORDON RAMSAY: So it literally
is indigenous to this area.
MAGNUS: It is.
We're very proud.
It's very popular,
especially around Christmas.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Little more.
MAGNUS: You have
to use your wrist.
Nei, nei, nei, nei.
So.
That's it?
Perfect.
Man, your uncle's amazing.
Do you ever upset him?
Yeah, a lot of times.
It's better.
Good.
GORDON RAMSAY: Good?
Better.
He's happy now.
He's been a little
bit tough on me.
Yeah, have been with
me for 10 years as well.
GORDON RAMSAY: He's
a proper Viking.
I'm dying to taste it.
- Perfect.
Oh, there it is there.
Wow, that's it there.
Yeah.
It's strong.
It's this cross between
a sort of cured salmon
but with a Vacheron cheese.
It was so strong, very acidic.
This is not very strong.
That's not very strong?
No.
Let's try a stronger one.
No, stop it.
MAGNUS: Let's try it.
- Really?
Stronger than that?
Let's try our special
Christmas batch.
Bloody hell.
(VOICEOVER) I'm worried
that special, in this case,
is not a good thing.
So what's special
about this batch?
MAGNUS: We have had
it in the barrel
for a longer amount of time.
Now, oh, my god,
the smell of that.
Bloody hell.
Pfft.
It doesn't look very appetizing.
And the smell gets stronger
the farther down the bucket
you go.
Bloody hell.
Seriously.
Oh my god.
This is sticky as--
[chuckles] Don't [bleep] around.
You don't eat this, do you?
Oh my god.
Mm.
You like that smell?
Yeah.
Oh, no.
[bleep] No.
Look at the juice.
The color of the juice.
MAGNUS: That's
the right texture.
Can you cut that, please?
Is this a joke?
Oh my lord.
Oh my god.
It's like putty.
Why is this so--
a special rare delicacy
when it stinks?
You should not
think about the smell.
It's the flavor.
Don't!
[chuckling]
GORDON RAMSAY: No, no, no.
MAGNUS: That's
the right texture.